frank how are we doing our 19 year old
daughter is pregnant with her second
child
my wife and i have legal custody or
guardianship of her first child
who's now three this pregnancy was also
unplanned
and so we are um struggling to find ways
to support her um and to
and to guide her because she's you know
not really been taking advice and so on
so
that's where we're at so when you talk
about um
number one i'm i'm glad you're there for
that little baby that's awesome
i know that wasn't how y'all drew that
up and y'all
had a whole different plan for this
season of life and um
it's awesome that y'all stepped up to
take care of that grandbaby
um when you say help and support what do
you mean
what are you thinking of when you wake
what picture do you have on how i can
support my daughter
when she won't listen to us right so
good question so the
so with the first baby um she was living
at home at the time
um and when the baby was about i don't
know
six eight months old um
she she confided in us that she was
having a really hard time
um you know being a mom which is totally
understandable it's hard being a mom for
anyone
as per your first caller you know you're
caller
and um let alone you know a 16 year old
single mom
at the time so anyway so we we um
with the guidance of our family
therapist at the time we
came up with a family plan whereby we
would take care of the baby
and our daughter would have a chance to
go back to school and get back on our
feet and all that stuff
so that was the support we provided at
that time
now since then yeah how did you end up
with custody that that's that means the
plan didn't work like y'all thought it
was going to huh
right so so exactly so
what happened was um she ended up moving
out of the house
um got into drugs and so on and so we
actually went to court
she moved out of the house without the
baby i should say she left the baby at
home with us okay
so we went to court and uh got a court
order
for custody custody to be granted to us
so
now is there any contingency on that or
that baby's yours
um it's a temporary order for the next
uh
i want to say three three or four years
okay um
sort of services to get to regain
custody or does it expire
um if the what the court order says is
that they will revisit the decision
at the ex the expiry of this first order
so she's got a chance to get her crap
together and if she doesn't
then they'll revisit it and then they'll
stamp it for you okay gotcha all right
thanks so now there's another one on the
way
correct with uh with a different young
man who is
um i would say equally as poor
performing as the first one
poor person you're the most you're the
most
articulate father i would have said the
dude sucks but
good for you you're a better person than
me i said all the words off there so
you don't want your grandkid to hear
about his dad you're a good man okay
so and i and and i know that i don't i
don't want to trash
the biological father of our
granddaughter in front of her right
i know better than to do that but this
this young man is is
is not much better to get it so she want
to keep this baby
yeah so she is she's definitely uh
keeping the baby she's doing august
um i think the due date is august 8th or
something like that but she's not living
at home
and what makes this situation kind of
funny or not funny but
um messy messy yeah is that she was
living
uh with him at his parents house
um but he had some sort of a nervous
breakdown a couple of weeks ago
he was hospitalized for a few days and
then prescribed
antidepressants and anti-anxiety meds
uh at which time his mother uh
kicked our daughter out of the house so
she's now living in a shelter
and us to you know
take any of the help that us as family
are trying to offer
why won't she why would she rather be
pregnant living in the shelter than come
back and live at home
yeah that's a great question and you
know
um we think she she's never been
diagnosed but we think she has
oppositional defiance disorder yeah hold
on i don't care about any disorders
why won't she why won't she
we don't allow her enough freedom
because she wants
the freedom to come and go as she
chooses and please us to do
okay um she like i said she was involved
in
doing drugs and drinking and stuff and
and all that stuff and
every time we tried to you know impose a
punishment or something
um it was nice as though we were
cramping her styling
so well you were rightfully so so is she
using drugs now
no she's clean now she's she's she's you
know
when she was telling my wife mom her mom
that
um she was pregnant you know she she was
telling her that she quit smoking and
she quit smoking weed and
and all the other stuff she was doing so
so she is living
in a shelter right now when's the baby
august uh august 8th i believe okay
so
[Music]
what do you what do you want to do
well you know she's 19 now you know
so there's very little we can do now
what do you want to do if you could snap
your fingers what would you have
happened
i would have her move back in either
with us or with her grandparents who've
also been very supportive
um i would want her to um
take advantage of the support that we're
lending her at least until this baby
comes and
until she can um find a job and get some
money in the bank
and you know develop some sort of a
foundation to live on her own
i don't have much faith that her
boyfriend is going to be
able to take care of them you know he
probably won't but
when's the last time you and her just
got together
and went wouldn't had lunch somewhere i
wouldn't ate too much pancakes
yeah it's been it's been a while would
she do that if you called her up
tomorrow and said hey let's go to
breakfast tomorrow
i'm paying uh would you come i think so
she might
yeah so do me this favor
don't do me a favor my life won't change
do yourself this favor
okay um spend a couple of days
really focusing on what what you
are willing to offer and what your
boundaries look like
and what you would love to see happen
and what is this within your power to
make happen
and then write it down
show it to your wife you all to do this
together make sure everybody's on the
same page
and then i want you in a low-key way no
drama no fanfare no
this is my last stand i want you to
invite your daughter breakfast
and i want you just to check in on her
see how she's doing
how's the pregnancy going and if your
wife's the right person for this that's
great too
she can have that meet that conversation
how's your body feeling i remember this
and that i remember when mom
i mean when my wife experienced xyz like
a human interaction
and then let her know i want you to know
we'd love to have you come home and
we've had our challenges in the past
you're 19 you're grown up now
we care about you and your health and
this baby's health
this is now going to be the brother or
sister of the other child
and we want you to know that you're
welcome home
that won't be the conversation for
fights it won't be the conversation for
for and if in my house you're not going
to be that's not that
this isn't that conversation this
conversation
is you being the dad you being the
grown-up
saying i miss my baby and i want you to
be safe
and okay over the next six months and if
boyfriend gets his gets well gets his
crap together gets on a right road and a
good trajectory awesome
but i want you to know that we came
after you because you're a daughter
you're still my baby girl i need no
you're 19 and you're about to be a
mother of two
but i want you know you can come home
the time for
there's no drugs in my house the time
for you have a curfew all those times
those conversations those boundary
conversations they have to happen
they don't have to happen now
and what you want to do is re-establish
trust in connection with your with your
baby girl okay
will that work am i pollyanna probably
but here's what i want
there's gonna either she's gonna say
she's gonna
drop her shoulders and say thank you so
much or i'll think about
it regardless of what happens she's
either going to come home
or she's going to wait three or four or
five more months
she's going to be real stubborn about
this she's going to find somebody else
to move in with she's going to find some
situation
and here's what i want her to have i
wanted to have
experiences letters first person
breakfast accounts whatever that my dad
kept coming for me he kept coming for me
and he kept coming for me because
there's gonna come a moment
when she's gonna hit rock bottom there's
gonna come a moment when she needs a
warm bed
and she's gonna remember that guy love
me or she's gonna have this baby in six
months in
she's gonna be so exhausted so tired so
fill in the blank
and she's gonna remember okay that guy
loved me because you're dealing with a
child right she's a kid
she's 19 right and so
give her a legacy of that and if she
says no say cool let's go to breakfast
again let's do breakfast every saturday
or me and mom are going to alternate
every saturday until this baby's born
just because we like you you're our
daughter
and all you're trying to do is not win
not establish boundaries not just
make sure fill in the blank you're just
trying to re-establish trust with your
daughter
she says no she says no say great i'm
gonna try again next week and this is
gonna be
real hard for you and your wife because
there's probably gonna be rejection
there's probably gonna be frustration
you're gonna see
she's gonna gain too much weight not
she's gonna lose a bunch of weight she's
not going to be healthy she's not going
to look like she's showered
it's going to be really hard and you all
have to be the super adults here and
keep going back
and going back and leaning in and
leaning in or the alternative is you can
cut her off
say best of luck to you i wish you well
oh we don't want to do that that's right
and i was going to tell you brother i
i couldn't do that to my daughter right
right yeah i'm going to have my
boundaries and i don't want to
i don't want you to hear me say man she
just gets to run roughshod over you guys
no
this is the prodigal son mom this is
like man come home
come home right and i also know that
when a teenager gets something in their
head
that is not accurate but that it gives
them an opportunity to pit themselves
against their family
man i'm gonna cut through all that
nonsense right i'm gonna cut through all
that crap i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be
a part of that this is the moment you
get to come home
right um when i say that how does that
sound frank
um yeah i i think
it sounds it sounds fine um you know
we've
we've definitely expressed that you know
the porch lights on and the doors open
uh but not in in such an intentional
manner like
like what you're like what you just
described so i think we can
we can try to continue expressing that
uh
in the way that you just described so do
you guys y'all laugh together when's the
last time you'll laugh together
uh well she was over when she actually
told us like three weeks ago she was
over
to visit with her daughter and visit
with the family
and you know we had a movie night and
popcorn and had a good time then and
that's actually when she
felt comfortable enough to tell us what
was going on so
yeah so she's a 19 year old mother of
two
she's an adult in the eyes of the law
and she's a kid
right and if this this may not work in
every family i've got a family with a
deranged sense of humor
but if this is me you know what my first
line would be
well we gave you a bunch of curfews and
rules
[Music]
that didn't work so come on all right i
mean we there's a there's an entryway to
this to be funny there's an entryway to
this to be really loving
yeah here's another beautiful thing if
you write her a letter so she can read
it when she leaves
a great thing 18 19 and 20 year olds are
are good at doing as
feeling really good in the moment they
get uncomfortable later on in the day
and the week with those
feelings like wait a minute i'm supposed
to hate my parents because they're
ruining my life
and i felt a sense of love for my dad
i gotta come up with some fill in the
blank right
if you write her a letter she can go
back to it and go back to it and go back
to it
so when she leaves the letter will have
nothing about rules those will come
the letter will have nothing about you
know you should have known better none
of that
the letter will just simply be you are
my baby girl
and i would love it if you came home i
want you to always know that we love you
your mom and i love you
we drive you crazy and you drive us
crazy
tag you're we're both hit right but you
and this new little grand baby are gonna
have a place to go
be hyper intentional be with not at
this is a mother of two man right
there's a mother too
be with not at and i hope man i'm so
hopeful that you can come in humbly
if there's things you need to apologize
for if you raise your voice yelled acted
like an idiot
this is that moment for you to go first
be humble just say because the goal here
is reconnection then not go
the goal here isn't to lecture right the
goal here is
safe baby and grandbaby the goal here is
not to win an argument and to
establish those boundaries those will
come this is the moment for connection
dude i love your heart frank let us know
how that conversation
goes let me know dude i'm gonna be
thinking about this one
let me know how that conversation goes
with you and your daughter
how that breakfast goes and man if she
comes back
moves back in with you guys we'll cheer
you on and if she doesn't we'll cheer
you on anyway man thank you so much for
that call